boris johnson no pierde la fe el primer
ministro de reino unido sigue confiando
en que el acuerdo comercial con eeuu
será uno de los mayores logros tras el
break si a pesar del poco entusiasmo
público del presidente joe biden
no no estoy de acuerdo con eso en
absoluto creo que hay todas las
perspectivas de un acuerdo de libre
comercio con eeuu pero mientras tanto lo
que estamos haciendo es tomar medidas
prácticas para ayudar a nuestros
exportadores así que ya vieron cómo se
ha levantado la prohibición sobre la
carne de res británica vieron cómo se
eliminaron los aranceles sobre el whisky
escocés sin embargo la primera visita de
johnson a la casa blanca esta semana
solo suscitó una fría respuesta aníbal
en sobre instalaciones
le preocupa el protocolo irlandés es eso
lo que está frenando este acuerdo con
reino unido
hay dos cuestiones distintas el acuerdo
con reino unido que se sigue discutiendo
pero en lo que respecta a los protocolos
estoy muy preocupado por ellos
y la declaración del presidente de eeuu
fue expresada de forma más contundente
por nancy pelosi durante su visita a
reino unido
esto no lo digo como una amenaza lo digo
como una predicción si se destruyen los
acuerdos del viernes santo es muy poco
probable que haya un acuerdo bilateral
entre el reino unido y eeuu
kane
mientras reino unido- sigue buscando un
acuerdo comercial bilateral con eeuu los
medios de comunicación británicos
sugieren que londres podría intentar
unirse al pacto entre eeuu méxico y
canadá aunque no está claro cómo podría
funcionar en la práctica
[Aplausos]